Matthew first of all what is it about
the guy that you seemed to just
gravitate towards who's a little outside
of the norms of societies not a nanner
yes but he's a little bit of an outlaw
and rebel you seem to really gravitate
towards those kinds of guys well they
are abject tortures outcasts a little
bit I mean what do you get with that and
I'm in a stereotype for a second
usually not people that are placate or
pander sure society's rules they usually
have their own sort of individual
constitution and have had to had to walk
their own individual path to succeed or
fail yeah this the one though was a
father and I was reminded earlier if I'm
actually this is only the second father
I've ever played interstellar in this so
this is a father but somebody there's a
lot of fathers in this predicament but
this is one of those guys he's a single
parent family wants to be best friends
with his kids which I've seen I've seen
that relationship and it didn't turn out
great for the kids no but this is also
in early 80s in poverty and southeast
Detroit so this is a guy who has great
dreams and hopes and all his heart's in
it but he just doesn't have that he
can't tow the line he can't get the job
done what do you learn from a guy like
Richie on set who hasn't been in the
game all that long can he teach you
something yes if fresh frost like yeah
you know it's what you knew before you
knew it's like you some some things you
not everything
knowledge and is it very good but
there's some things where you learn not
learn better you learn worse yeah he's
up for question oh yeah you know and and
the script isn't a blueprint that has to
be you know to house your building that
has to be absolutely I did - he he he
would we would give him free rein to
like trust his instincts here in there
and my views like not technically
proficient enough and talented enough to
just to pivot and adjust and hold me
onto his frequency in order to give the
kid some a certain amount of freedom
within the same
and you know there is that enthusiasm
that comes with you when seeing it for a
first perspective there were times where
there we did laugh out loud it was so
that's a time where you know I pushed
him hard and he said to me look man I
didn't want to be in the movies yeah
there's a 20% chance every night this
young man might get on a bus back to
Baltimore it's amazing you've done that
sort of late 70s 80s thing it when you
put those clothes on how much do those
outfits help because the fashion in this
movie spectacular I mean they help I
mean they're the packaging for the
product yeah I do the inside work first
and then that becomes really fun cuz the
hair and they go with Brian and you go
and you find these people who are blue
collar and then in the early 80s and
lived in those areas and here look
photographs you're trying the real
people you're not finding people to
Magda's for the story something it
starts to slowly come alive and he
starts this new work and we all every
one was coming for authenticity that's
thing you know the fact that the
director and the studio were brave
enough to say we'll bank this movie with
an untested not actor in the lead
yeah really makes me as an actor for the
reason I came in the project oh yes okay
we're gonna go for authenticity that
whole way no one's ever gonna try and
condense this in a moderniser story to
make it safer or to make it more
digestible for people so it was that's
what we set out to tell from the
beginning and I'm real happy with the
film brilliant thank you so much guys
thank you